Rossi's sticking around for our next
guest who likes to put his coconut oil
in his coffee
it's true how does detective Drew find
these cracks
please welcome my dear friend founder of
naturally Danny CEO magazine and Drew
crew or Danny Sia
[Applause]
what are we making today baseball it's
spring and I love this because there are
edible flowers do you like edible
flowers I love an edible flower I
usually think of the pansy very good we
got pansies in here so this is a
spring-tastic pasta dish one of my
favorite fantastic favorite dishes from
the magazines also in my cookbook but
it's so simple to make is all you need
is pasta a blender a couple of basic
ingredients fresh flowers and some
zucchini and you've got dinner I'm so
hungry I'm so excited what do we do
first so all right help me make the
sauce yes what am I doing so we're gonna
dump um yellow peppers all into a
blender let's go straight very good for
you lemon juice I love this one because
that's like sunshine don't you love like
fresh lemon and even if it's chilly
outside it's still like a little warm
the balance of acid is necessary
do you love nutritional yeast I know it
looks like fish flakes like fish food
but really Bonito it's a deactivated
yeast like gives it that cheesy flavor
so if you're lactose intolerant or
avoiding Dairy this is where you get
that cheesy flavor in there and then
some pepper and we also have almond
butter in here if you are allergic to
nuts you can do sun butter and then can
you do sun better allergic to nuts yeah
that's sunflower yeah exactly and then
we just blend away right here
[Applause]
that's it how how easy is that right
I have some boiling water here so we've
got our cooked linguine but you can help
me make the ribbon oh great
okay and this is so simple the trick to
make teach me I don't know how to do
this you want to be firm you don't want
to be gentle with this so you just go
yeah look at that hello and this is the
fun part because these ribbons are also
like another like noodle yeah a zoodle
Okay Ross you did a great job thank you
I'm not done yet
I'm enjoying this yeah okay what's next
let's toss the pasta okay so let's just
throw it in the pan you can do it you
can do this in the bowl you can do in
this pan whatever you want to juice do
you like a pan because it gives a little
heat and helps like melty melty
everything yeah you want this to be warm
yeah yeah yeah I like a little warmth
sauce in here I love the color of this
sauce look at that you guys and it's
going to be really thick what you can do
if you need a little help you can take a
little Ladle of water yeah some pasta
water in there which is really pasta
water it's got that starch it's got that
salt it's got that flavor
and by the way this is it so what we're
gonna do that's it if you could just
give me a little serving of course I
compare on my plate how do you make it
pretty they do that thing where they
twist it right twist it Roti do it yeah
yeah yeah yeah
put in some of your zucchini where is it
okay
popping seeds coffee seeds oh
I see the poppy said some red pepper
flakes and then always crushed red
pepper let's pick some flowers oh yes
please look at how fun this makes it I
have to say I
I know it's beautiful but get the kids
into this come on I mean it's really
beautiful Danny I'm gonna grab this one
can I take a bite take a bite it's so
I'm going straight in with the yellow
flower and taking a bite this looks so
good gosh darn it I am so hungry it's my
favorite my mouth is watering okay ready
um
[Music]
it's so lemony that's it it's that lemon
it's so fresh oh my gosh wow and it is
creamy and it tastes like spring in a
bowl Danny beautiful and the best part
is you can eat the flowers oh hey
[Applause]
he's very chicken edible flowers just
don't go in your yard and pick whatever
speaking of what else can you do with
this well if you have leftover flowers
or if you do have regular flowers in
your yard we're gonna make something
where you can embellish boring candles
to the prettiest floral pressed I have
boring basic candlesticks right now and
I'm so in all right you're not going to
want to miss this we're going to upgrade
your Candlestick like nobody's business
[Music]
foreign